now sheikh abdullahi is someone you guys
don't know i know myself personally
i was getting to know a specific sister
for marriage and um
things were going okay they seemed they
were gone what happened is i saw this
sister in my dream i saw her and she had
tattoos yeah on her arms okay and then i
saw some other elements of the dream and
he said when he showed me that
and he said something along the lines
i'm going to be injured like i don't
know if
i can't remember i was blown or when i
was up fam
i'm so sorry there's i there is i don't
know what other way
you could know that
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum today better care to
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah now in
this video this is a very unique video
here because this is something that i
personally experienced with
a dream interpreter now sheikh abdul
aziz is someone you guys don't know i
know myself
personally i've met him abdullah his dad
his father was involved in great dawah
working and he was known
in the dow field and you know uh in the
arabian peninsula et cetera so now
i came across him and he shared a secret
with me you know he didn't it wasn't
something where he's
talking about it's just i think we was
talking about dreams i can't remember
yeah so he came to me personally and he
shared that experience that he
is gifted with dream interpretation and
we know from the prophetic you know
sunnah and we know from the quran as
well
that you know certain people are gifted
with this and one of those is like for
example the anbiya the
you know the the messengers of god
almighty allah now with me it's it's a
bit
strange because obviously when you hear
this stuff you're like oh man you know
it might be one of those pierced up kind
of things like
you know how can you trust him like oh
you know and obviously
and he seemed like i'm sure a beautiful
brother yeah he's someone that i i love
spending time with her
he's you know helped me in many ways may
allah bless him and
um so basically i had a dream now this
stream connects at a marriage
documentary i know i know i'll give you
guys a promise
by the end of this year i do not release
the app if the app is not ready i'm
going to release part one of it
inshallah okay
the reason i'm saying that bonus is
because i don't want the documentary on
its own the app would really help you
guys and i'm going to tell you guys why
because it connects with the stream
interpretation now what happened is i
was getting to know a specific sister
for marriage
and um things were going okay they
seemed they were going okay um and i
actually approached this in a very
unique way i actually wrote a letter now
writing a letter i wasn't i could love
that it was just basically my intentions
that's correct zeeshan my intentions of
wanting to get into november and i
expressed that in a letter because there
was a different form in my marriage
documentary i was exploring different
avenues
of getting like approach and assist in a
halal way and that's what i want to
share with you guys
so you come to that letter thing in the
documentary we've documented all et
cetera here
however what happened is i saw this
sister in my dream um and it wasn't like
again uh
it wasn't something where it's like oh
my gosh like the one thing islam i love
about islam is it protects you you know
from the soul
falling into falling in love etc
alhamdulillah any sister i was getting
to know for marriage no matter how long
i was going to know them for there was
never that connection of love involved
because you had your boundaries it was
like it's for sake of allah it's for
marriage etc
however i saw her in a dream in a weird
way in the context where um
i saw her and she had tattoos yeah on
her arms okay and then i saw some other
elements of the dream where i saw my
cousin and there was like
there was this like this massive wall
and uh etc
so now i wanted to share that in dream
with
shah abdul aziz because i thought okay
what could it be is it a sign and this
is where
a lot of you guys were looking to get
married this is where you would want to
like you know what okay
how's this the harder work and that's
the reason we're developing the app
because
we want to educate people into the
marriage seeking process by so they can
know
everything what is this takara is it
through dreams how do you know so i had
that personal experience and i said
i said i have this dream and in this
room i saw this system i'm getting to
know for marriage
and does this show like is is it a bad
sign is it a good sign what is it please
tell me so i sent i told him my dream so
obviously his
english is good but explanation-wise you
know
i understand why it could be a little
bit there might be a little bit
obstacles
so i explained the dream to him in
detail and you know i try my best to go
into details etc
and he translated he did an
interpretation of the dream
and this made me be like yo hold on a
second
hold hold on a second i take my glass
over that
you really are gifted with this and i
tested him in two incidents yeah this is
the first one yeah and
i said to him the dream i told him what
i saw in the dream etc
you know that the sister i'm getting off
her marriage she wasn't wearing a hijab
she had tattoos and she was sat down and
there's some other details here so
he messaged me and he goes um you had an
accident
and i was like yo and then he couldn't
explain to me in detail
and he was trying to say that you're
going to hit the left side of your car
so because he can explain it what you
can see on the screen is
actually him pointing out he took a
picture from google he showed the car
yeah that's not my car
and he pointed out where the accident
will happen and when he said when he
showed me that
and he said something along the lines
i'm going to be injured like i don't
know if
i can't remember i was blown away
because the dream had
nothing to do with the accident he's
telling me that i've had an accident
i think said i had an accident or i'm
going to have an accident and he pointed
out the place that i'm going to the
car's gonna be
you know hit and i was like wow i was
blown away
now the reason i'm mentioning this guy
with this with you guys robin sisters is
not the talk about this because that's
going to be discussed in the marriage
documentary but shaykh abdullah is
hamdullah and i said to him i gave the
idea i said
why don't you make this into something
where you can do you know for the people
and he said obviously some people come
to him you know a lot and people come
obsessed with et cetera you know like
very curious i said look do it
charge a little fee whatever it may be
and at least you get serious people
coming et cetera yeah and he's done that
he's developed an app and in this app
brother and sisters and
i can vouch for him he's not someone
that's you know money motivated et
cetera he's a businessman
but he's done this and um i'm telling
you guys that he's
launched the app go check the app out
inshallah and it's in english and an
arabic inshallah
and he will interpret your dreams and
for me that was blown away and there was
another instance
where um a somebody got in contact with
me yeah and said that basically um
someone in their family saw a dream that
one of their teeth i think their
uh the canine teeth was wobbling yeah
and he came to me and come on tv and he
goes basically
um the sister has um you know her
ovaries yeah she has a problem
uh with the left one and she will get
her period soon and i was like
teeth period and while he unbelievable
unbelievable yeah i conveyed it back to
this
family member and they were like here
the sister basically hasn't been having
her period for this amount of time and
she's got problem on the left and i was
up
fam i'm so sorry there's there's i don't
know
what other way you could know that and
interpret it that way so i'm just
sharing this video with you guys
promises in a nutshell
his app is here you can see on the
screen inshallah download it use it
inshallah he is someone from the quran
in the sun alhamdulillah you know he's
someone that we know alhamdulillah uh he
follows the quran
so that's it and uh the whole story of
the sister and the
except how that went you'll find it in
the mars documentary i'll just share
that with you guys hope you guys
benefited inshallah it was amazing it
amazed me two times
and allah has gifted him with that and
may allah enable him to use that in the
right way like he is
enjoy it inshallah and download the
openness download the app not the
app now till next time
too